Marvel fans, I am
joined by Xochitl Gomez.
How's it going?
I'm doing great.
I'm nervous.
I'm excited.
INTERVIEWER: What are you
looking forward to seeing
most in this film tonight?
Well, number one,
my homies, Benedict
Cumberbatch and Benny Wong.
Gotta support the crew.
I'm really excited to see
just this movie in general.
Have you been a Spider-Man
fan for a long time?
Oh yeah.
I'm like-- who hasn't been
since like five years old?
I mean, are you kidding me?
[LAUGHING]
INTERVIEWER: That makes sense.
You're-- you're right.
So there's quite a bit of
crossover between the cast
and the cast in
your upcoming film,
Marvel Studios' Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness.
What is it like
working with Benedict
Cumberbatch and Benedict Wong?
Oh, I mean, it's
pretty insane.
I'm a pretty lucky person.
It's pretty crazy.
I just love watching them get in
their character and their zone.
And it's just been wonderful,
like, teaching experience,
honestly.
It's just crazy to be like, oh
my gosh, I know these people.
It's kind of funny.
I bet.
Who are you excited to see most
on this red carpet tonight?
Zendaya.
Girl, yes.
I'm excited.
I'm like-- I'm like,
is she here now?
I'm waiting for the scream.
I know.
There.
I hear some screams.
Could be her.
So I heard you skateboard.
Is that true?
Yes, I do a little
bit of skateboarding.
But ever since I started getting
some, like, roles I was like,
I can't really
injure myself here.
So I just--
I just graze a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
No crazy trick.
No, no, no.
No.
I might be able to have,
like, some fake blood
and stuff for work, but
not nothing in real life.
Nuh uh.
That's a cool skill to have.
And you just celebrated
your quinceanera?
Yes, I did.
It was during COVID and
stuff, so I couldn't really
have some, like, huge
thing, which, I mean,
I really wish I could have.
But I just went around the
park and around just LA
and just took some photos.